so
okay so my
my center
is dependent upon
the periphery right
and in this case what makes up the
periphery
my head and my feet hence our rule
if my head goes down
at least one foot has to come up this is
a breaking a center
okay yes i still have a center of
gravity but in terms of the spiraling
rotating cross
i'm not doing it in my body anymore okay
so my
body stays locked
and i do that same thing
this whole thing is going to rotate
not on a circle
has to go on a spiral
okay
which means it must seek some sort of
traversing vector it must have some sort
of depth okay
so
my
body's going to go this way my body's
going to go that way my body's not going
to go this way okay i think that's part
of the problem
um
is is why you have to disengage that
tail bone at the end because there's no
room for it you have to get your legs
back under you you understand so you
start you roll in this way
and there's no
there's no room for your legs so you're
going to bend your knees a lot
and disengage the tailbone
this kind of thing but i don't do that
because
i have depth
my legs are out my legs are at home
you see how my legs are out
watch my legs again lock my body lock my
body boom
[Music]
okay let's try it again
so again if i go straight
then his forward roll any forward roll
kind of works any forward over okay
but if i am trying to do the spiraling
cross geometry
it doesn't go on a circle it's going to
go on a spiral it's going to
seek depth
and then come around
it's not going to go straight it's not
going to get straight i'm going to go
straight
it's one big spiraling rock
he's feeling
a young young
clap so to speak
on your part his projection
okay
so
we come around
and if he goes straight
i could do whatever
but when he does that spiral
i have to seek
that depth
and
a yang yin yin yang reconciliation
okay
so instead of going here
and going
i would look at why did i feel your
elbow
and you felt my elbow too
so we'll go so you can see it slow so
you can feel it
it's right there you
see
but watch me go around
this cross
this cross right here
watch watch it go slower so you can feel
it you feel that there is there's a
clash
i'm gonna go
you feel that yes
and as a result
he can't he won't project me it just
gets reconciled but i do lose my balance
he goes i'm going around it
you watch my hips again
i'm reconciling
some clues to look
is because he's not projecting me
my shoulder is actually
on the mat
before we even let go on the other one
your shoulders about
three feet four feet
you're watching the elbow energy
be reconciled
by the uke
but it's that same
rotating cross
against the rotating cross
okay
uh
we're in i come here like this
and then you are now just stepping
around the guy and now doing your
regular
forward rolls out
okay
but you can't do that can you and you're
not going
why is that
is your racism yes my my leg is checking
that leg out you see
so we're gonna come over here like this
this leg is going that way
okay
um
so that would
not be it
okay
uh when i get something else i pick
andrew because he's he's bigger he's
stronger than me okay
um if i
establish a relationship to my head feet
then i establish a center you see the
periphery is related to each other
then the center is established that
means
that's as heavy as i'm going to get
okay
when i walk around
or i break center
i'm very light
is it okay okay
so
uh
we'll have you
try it and you'll feel what i'm talking
about is that she has my whole magazine
as my whole mass jacked her up okay
whereas if i would lose
and lose she can do it
incrementally
but if i have my
periphery related
and center this is very
and it starts to expose things
in her technique
now all i do is maintain center
let me see like that beat there it's not
marshall that's where they do counters
here and stuff like that do you guys got
that
okay so
uh
don't try to step around it
um
and you you can make sure that you are
always getting that leg
keep your circle
that just be calm
be calm accept
um
watch my face
[Music]
okay
um
let's try it again
okay so the question is
what is the growth stimulus training
your uk or you came at mine and you guys
nailed it it's way faster and now the
question is why is it faster
and you said
we usually are having energy right okay
you're adding energy to it so
diagnose how is the energy being added
to it
we're not just taking vagus growth we
are putting ourselves towards them i
would say no you are being accelerated
where is your acceleration point
set the elbow
your elbows being accelerated into the
technique
how is that doable if you're resisting
with the elbow yeah you have a young
young contact point there you get it so
you'll you'll feel you'll feel it as we
go right here
feel when it goes off here it's on on
and off
and i just do that from the start
this goes boom
so my roll
is not accelerating
i don't get projected
my roll
if we go slow
slower
you see
this
here
is the yong yang
this is the cross
there's the cross
and it's going to rotate
wait
it's going to rotate i'm going to not do
my feet now
in trade positions
[Music]
okay you got it
okay
so as you're doing your kimmy try to get
it off
by
keeping
your own rotating cross inside your own
body okay
try it again